[Music]
in systemd this is a store and what I
mean by that is that this is a
photograph I took in macoco shantytown
in Lagos Nigeria it's built over the
lagoon and there are no streets where
there can be stores to shop and so the
store comes to you and in the same
community
this is business synergy this is the
boat that that lady was paddling around
in and this artisan makes the boat and
the paddles and sells directly to the
people who need the boat in the paddles
and this is a global business
okand I Rose smokes fish in macoco in
Lagos and I asked her where does the
fish come from and I thought she'd say
oh you know up the lagoon somewhere or
maybe across Africa but you'll be happy
to know she said that came from here it
comes from the North Sea Scott here
frozen shipped down to Lagos smoked and
sold for tiny increment the profit on
the streets of Lagos and this is a
business incubator this is all the
source and dump the largest garbage dump
in Lagos and 2,000 people work here and
I found this out from this fellow Andrew
Subaru Andrew spent 16 years scavenging
materials on the dump earned enough
money to turn himself into a contract
scaler which meant he carried the scale
and went around and we'd all the
materials that people had scavenged from
the dump now he's a scrap dealer that's
his little Depot behind him and he earns
twice the Nigerian minimum wage this is
a shopping mall this is her shoddy
market in Lagos Jorge Luis Borgess has a
story called The Aleph and the olive is
a point in the world where absolutely
everything exists and for me this image
is a point in the world where absolutely
everything exists so what am I talking
about when I talk about systemd it's
traditionally called the informal
economy the underground economy the
black market
I don't conceive of it that way I think
it's really important to understand that
something like this is totally open it's
right there for you to find all of this
is happening openly and aboveboard
there's nothing
underground about it it's our
prejudgment that it's underground
I've pirated the term systemd from the
former French colonies there's a word in
French that is debris or die's that
means to be self-reliant and the former
French colonies have turned that into
systemd for the economy of self-reliance
or the DIY economy but governments hate
the DIY economy and that's why I took
this picture in 2007 and this is the
same market in 2009 and I think when the
organizers of this conference we're
talking about radical openness they
didn't mean that the street should be
open and the people should be gone I
think what we have is a pickle problem I
had a friend who worked at a pickle
factory and the cucumber's would come
flying down this conveyor belt and his
job was to pick off the ones that didn't
look so good and throw them in the bin
labeled relish where they'd be crushed
and mixed with vinegar and used for
other kinds of profit this is the pickle
economy we're all focusing on this is a
statistic from earlier this month in the
Financial Times we're all focusing on
the luxury economy it's worth 1.5
trillion dollars every year and that's a
vast amount of money right that's three
times the gross domestic product of
Switzerland so it's vast but it should
come with nasty risk and the asterisk is
that it excludes two-thirds of the
workers of the world 1.8 billion people
around the world work in the economy
that is unregulated and informal it's a
huge number and what does that mean well
it means if it were united in a single
political system one country call it the
United street sellers Republic the USSR
or bazzara Stan it would be worth 10
trillion dollars every year and that
would make it the second largest economy
in the world after the United States and
given that projections are that the bulk
of economic growth over the next 15
years will come
from emerging economies in the
developing world
it could easily overtake the United
States and become the largest economy in
the world so the implications of that
are vast because it means that this is
where employment is 1.8 billion people
and this is where we can create a more
egalitarian world because people are
actually able to earn money and live and
thrive as Andrew Subaru did big
businesses have recognized this and
what's fascinating about this slide it's
not that the guys can carry boxes on
their heads and run around without
dropping them off it's that the Gallo
sausage roll is a product that's made by
a global company called UAC Foods that's
active throughout Africa in the Middle
East but the Gallo sausage roll is not
sold in stores
UAC Foods has recognized that it won't
sell if it's in stores it's only sold by
a phalanx of street hawkers who run
around the streets of Lagos at bus
stations and in traffic jams and sell it
as a snack and it's been sold that way
for 40 years it's a business plan for a
corporation and it's not just in Africa
here's mr. clean-looking amorously at
all the other Procter & Gamble products
and Procter & Gamble you know the
statistic always cited is that Walmart
is their largest customer and it's true
as one store Walmart buys 15% does 15%
of Procter & Gamble's businesses with
Walmart but their largest market segment
is something that they call high
frequency stores which is all these tiny
kiosks and the lady in the canoe and all
these other businesses that exist in
systemd the informal economy and Procter
& Gamble makes twenty percent of its
money from that market segment and it's
the only market segment that's growing
so Procter & Gamble says we don't care
whether a stall store is incorporated or
registered or anything like that we want
our products in that store
and then there's mobile phones this is
an ad for MTN which is a South African
multinational active in about 25
countries and when they came into
nigeria nigeria is the big dog in africa
one in seven Africans is a Nigerian and
so everyone wants into the mobile phone
market in Nigeria and when MTN came in
they wanted to sell the mobile service
like I get in the United States or like
people get here in the UK or in Europe
expensive monthly plans you get a phone
you pay overages you're you're killed
with fees and their plan crashed and
burned and they went back to the drawing
board and they retooled and they came up
with another plan
we don't sell you the phone we don't
sell you the monthly plan
we only sell you airtime and where's the
airtime sold it's sold at umbrella
stands all over the streets where people
are unregistered unlicensed but MTN
makes most of its profits perhaps 90% of
its profits from selling through systemd
the informal economy and where do the
phones come from well they come from
here this is in Guangzhou China and if
you go upstairs in this rather
sleepy-looking
electronics mall you find the guangzhou
da chateau secondhand trade center and
if you go in there you follow the guys
with the muscles who are carrying the
boxes and where are they going they're
going to Eddie in Lagos now most of the
phones they are not secondhand at all
the name is a misnomer most of them are
pirated they have the name brand on them
but they're not manufactured by the name
brand
now are there downsides to that well I
guess you know China has no no
intellectual property right the Versace
without the vowels Joe money instead of
Armani as Gucci
all around the world this is how
products are being distributed so for
instance in one Street Market on who of
inches encode a Marta so in San Paulo
Brazil you can buy fake designer glasses
you can buy cloned cologne you can buy
pirated DVDs of course you can buy New
York Yankees caps and all sorts of
unauthorised patterns you can buy
quickest parathas designer underwear
that isn't really manufactured by a
designer and even pirated the
evangelical mixtapes now businesses tend
to complain about this and they're I
don't want to take away from their
entire validity of complaining about it
but I did ask a major sneaker
manufacturer earlier this year what they
thought about piracy and they told me
well you can't quote me on this because
if you quote me on this I have to kill
you
but they use piracy as market research
the sneaker manufacturer told me that if
they find that Pumas are being pirated
or adidas are being pirated and their
sneakers aren't being pirated they know
they've done something wrong so it's
very important to them to track piracy
exactly because of this and the people
who are buying the Pirates are not their
customers anyway because their customers
want the real deal now there's another
problem this is a real street sign in
Lagos Nigeria all of systemd
really doesn't pay taxes right and when
I think about that first of all I think
the government is a social contract
between the people and the government if
the government isn't transparent and the
people aren't going to be transparent
either but also that we're blaming the
little guy who doesn't pay his taxes and
we're not recognizing that everyone's
fudging things all over the world
including some extremely respected
businesses and I'll give you one example
there was one company that paid four
thousand bribes in the first decade of
this millennium and a million dollars in
bribes every business day right all over
the world and that company was the big
German electronics giant Siemens
this goes on in the formal economy as
well as the informal economy so it's
wrong of us to blame and I'm not
singling out Siemens I'm saying everyone
does it okay I just want to end by
saying that if Adam Smith had framed out
a theory of the flea market instead of
the free market what would be some of
the principles first it would be to
understand that it could be considered a
cooperative and this is a thought from
the Brazilian legal scholar Roberto
mangabeira Unger cooperative development
is a way forward secondly from the Swiss
anarchist philosopher paul fire-up and
facts are relative and what is a massive
rate of self-reliance through a Nigerian
businessperson is considered
unauthorized and horrible to other
people and we have to recognize that
there a difference in how people define
things and what their facts are and
third is and I'm taking this from the
great American beat poet Allen Ginsberg
that alternate economies barter and
different kinds of currency alternate
currencies are also very important and
he talked about buying what he needed
just with his good looks and so I just
want to leave you there and say that
this economy is a tremendous force for
global development and we need to think
about it that way thank you very much
[Applause]